Controlled for a reason,
they are dangerous.
Drugs are wonderful drugs when you have
a medical need for them.
In fact,
most of the medical needs have
disappeared over the years for anabolic
steroids,
radios,
other drugs,
what are anabolic steroids,
anabolic steroids,
and nothing more or less than synthetic
derivatives of the male hormone,
testosterone,
uh,
and uh,
molecules have been modified for a
variety of reasons where she can get
into,
but fundamentally a,
they're all variations of the
testosterone molecule and you know,
we have a surgeon that and puberty and
that it levels off or people have taken
a anabolic steroids to try to become
more than they otherwise would be.
So they're looking for increased
strength,
improve recovery time,
more aggressiveness and assertiveness.
A more acceleration,
uh,
it,
it does work.
It can't just take the anabolic steroid,
go to sleep,
wake up stronger.
Uh,
you do have to work out,
they have to put your muscles under
stress and resistive exercises.
You have to be in a high protein diet.
And there was a big debate for many
years.
The American Medical Association for
years did nothing.
Well,
the athletes knew better.
It clearly does work,
but it is clearly dangerous and they
side effects can be in the short term,
the long term,
some are protected,
some are not protectable,
some of all the secondary sex
characteristics and effects on other
parts of the body.
Uh,
the psychiatric effects.
There's a profound depression when you
stop these drugs.
Uh,
we can talk about that later as well,
but there's a for teenagers as a
particular concern in that they will
close their growth centers and their
long bones,
so they never achieved there.
They're genetically determined height.
They're going to permanently shorter
than they would have been otherwise.
And for teenagers,
very importantly,
as well as other abuses,
severe acne is coming.
So that's part of the package as well.
There are some effects that could affect
a teenager's men and women alike.
Are those things that affect women?
There are,
those things were fixed.
Teenagers and those things that affect
males.
The simplest term a male becomes
feminized.
Why?
Because in the body,
testosterone is transformed into the
female hormone estrogen.
And so you'll see a high pitched voice,
uh,
development of breasts,
a shrinkage of their testicles.
A changing their hair patterns,
they literally become feminized while
they're trying to get increasingly
masculinized sort of a strange paradox.
They also get bigger and stronger,
but they also get families and some of
those changes permanent.
Conversely,
a woman that takes anabolic steroids
becomes masculinized associated,
will develop a deep voice,
develop facial hair,
a clitoral enlargement,
menstrual irregularities,
uh,
and a large Adam's apple.
Uh,
so they've very much become the
direction of a male.
And as far as teenagers a concern,
the thing that's unique to them of
course,
as is the growth centers and the fact
that they never reached their full
genetic potential if they take these
things long enough.
So,
uh,
each segment of the population has its
unique consequences from abusing
anabolic steroids.
Well,
I can tell you a very concrete example.
Uh,
there's a,
about three years ago,
I got a phone call one day from Mr Don.
Don Hooten,
who lived in Texas,
had a son who was 16 years old,
who pitched for,
for his baseball team in Plano.
Texas was very good.
Coincidentally,
had a cousin who played in the major
leagues,
uh,
by the name of Bert Hooten,
at the end of the season.
And his coach said,
look,
you want to get to the major leagues
like your cousin.
You just keep working the way you are,
but you've got to get bigger.
I left the event.
Well being in Texas,
it was very hard to get to Mexico and
Mexico.
Anabolic steroids are readily available
and so off.
When the son Taylor Hudl and in fact got
bigger,
stronger acne and personality changed.
Roid rage puts a visceral wall,
very significant breakup on his
relationship with his girlfriend's
parents,
for them around to various experts in
understand what was going on.
A parents finally said,
look,
you have to stop this.
And he did one day and went up to his
room,
took two belts and hanged himself,
called me shortly thereafter and said,
he just felt compelled to share this
horrible story with other parents so
they don't want up in a similar
situation.
And I suggested to him that he
established a not for profit foundation
educational foundation,
which will,
uh,
devote itself to getting this message
out.
And that gave rise to the tail,
the Hilton Foundation,
which I'm chairman of the board and Mr
[inaudible] testified as I did before
the hearings in Congress baseball,
uh,
and,
at the Metro report you met with Senator
Mitchell,
uh,
leadership in many aspects of this
field.
And,
uh,
we're happy to report that makes me
baseball actually is granted in a
substantial amount of money to Taylor
who foundation to do what we call is a
hoot,
hoots chalk talks and which we will run
it all 30 major league stadiums around
the United States.
A session is devoted to steroid abuse
prevention and healthy alternatives to
using steroids.
So it's a long way of saying that it was
a very significant price to pay a in
this.
And,
uh,
you know,
we heard about the wrestling case of a
restaurant now when he committed
suicide,
killed his wife and young child.
Uh,
these are horrible stories,
but they're not rare.
And then not unpredictable.
Uh,
and most people don't recognize or
concentrated on the psychiatric aspects
of steroid abuse as much as they do on
some of the other aspects,
particularly was doing baseball records
in the line.
Yeah.
We have parents
recognize that a teenager has increased
in their own testosterone and another
individual in the same age group may
have a rise because they're taking
testosterone or other anabolic steroids.
So how do you distinguish a kid?
It was going through a difficult
adolescence,
took no drugs,
but as a lot of acne is irritable,
changing his relationships with his
friends,
a wants to look good.
Well,
so the gym,
how do you take that individual and
contrast that for a parent and I suspect
that their kid is using drugs and got
acne and going to the gym and doing all
these things.
They have to a,
be aware that it's a possibility in this
day and age and it's a sad thing to say
that they're adolescents,
in fact,
maybe using anabolic steroids,
but they also have to recognize.
I can make that assumption.
It may be that the kids are already
going through a difficult adolescence.
Imagine how bad it can be suddenly your
parents questioning you and your
behaviors,
so if in doubt you have to seek a
solution with a physician and share that
information with your physician.
And then there are ways to evaluate
what's the tool is at play here.
But you know,
for the average teenager it may be not
so obvious whether this is natural,
whether this is driving.